welcome back here to good day las vegas
as you see there metro sheriff joe
lombardo joins us once again for our
morning cup of joe's segment sheriff
good to see you again again
good seeing you john so let's talk about
an increase we've seen in homicides
murders across the valley as we move
to the halfway point of 2021 is there
any pattern
in some of the cases that detectives are
investigating right now
we've had a 54 increase in homicides
compared to last year
but with that being said we've also had
a decrease
in the last couple months in the numbers
um so earl
earlier in the year you know like
unfortunately we were around 120
percent increase so we're going in the
right direction
but to answer your question in
particular to maybe there's a trend or
something associated with it and
and i guess the most important piece is
domestic violence that's been the most
common cause
of the homicides year to date this year
what kind of
crimes increase in southern nevada
during the summer months and what should
people watch out for
you know the kids are out of school
young adults are out of school
property crimes tend to increase during
the summer months idle hands
you know that saying not significant
property crimes but petty
property crimes so we have to be aware
of that thefts from vehicles
some home burglaries during the
summer months because kids are not being
watched in
in that case but on top of that when we
look at violent crime
there's a lot of anxiety with the heat
of the summer
and domestic violence increases during
the heat alcohol consumption
and everything associated with that type
of issue we have to be aware of during
the summer
sheriff recently the city of las vegas
agreed to rename a portion of tp
lane that's up by iron mountain and
brent lane
to eric lloyd street you uh we as we
know we were close with eric lloyd who
lost his life to the coronavirus did a
lot of work for the department in the
community
uh tell me about the meaning of that
honor to you and
and to the department as a whole it is
up in the northwest
uh in a master plan community eric lloyd
street
it's important for people to remember
and to have a
monument by a street name is is very
beneficial to the family and to the
metro family that we can continue to
recognize eric lloyd
for his sacrifice and i just want to
thank the city of las vegas for what
they do
now we ask viewers sheriff four
questions that we can ask you on their
behalf and the number one response we
get is about cars across the valley with
no tags or expired tags now the dmv has
been behind because of the pandemic but
is this an issue for metro patrol
officers as they're out on the street
they see these tags that are maybe
expired or not even there
yeah it's an issue and unfortunately
that would result in the pandemic
that we experienced all through 2020
were the most of 2020 so
in march to june i believe it is
there was a moratorium on vehicle
registration because dmv was shut down
so
if you encounter it take care of it
it'll take a while for us to
jump i think we're all still trying to
catch up from the pandemic in a variety
of different ways sheriff
yeah thank you thank you chef for
joining us this morning if you have a
question like that for the sheriff you
can submit it to us of course
just head to 8newsnow.com and find out
if it's answered every wednesday